luego de la decisión del ministro
federal de inmigración de australia de
cancelar por segunda vez la visa de
novak djokovic el tenista fue detenido y
pasará la noche en el mismo hotel de
migración donde estuvo durante cinco
días tras su llegada a australia los
ojos del mundo están puestos en la
audiencia programada para este domingo a
las nueve y media de la mañana fecha y
hora locales de melbourne allí se
discutirá la apelación radicada por los
abogados de djokovic un dato importante
es que la corte decidió que la audiencia
no será presidida por un juez sino por
tres es decir por la sala plena esto
implica que sea cual sea la decisión que
tome ninguna de las partes tendrá la
opción de apelar la defensa del serbio
solicitó esta posibilidad con la cual el
gobierno no estaba de acuerdo mientras
tanto varios de los tenistas que van a
participar en el abierto de tenis han
reaccionado rafael nadal rival directo
de djokovic para disputar el título dijo
que está cansado de la controversia a la
cual ha calificado como un circo además
según él ningún jugador es más
importante que el torneo y que con o sin
djokovic el abierto de australia será
genial la tenista japonesa naomi o xhaka
actual campeona
de grand slam calificó la situación como
desafortunada y dijo que es triste que
muchas personas vayan a recordar al
djokovic por lo que está pasando la
situación migratoria y djokovic podría
decidirse finalmente este domingo un día
antes de que inicie el torneo la
organización ya tiene un plan de
contingencia en caso de que el tenista
número uno del planeta no pueda defender
su título